hello everyone and welcome to today's
giveco galaxy tour webinar
on mastering basic cell culture
techniques
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrus and brought to you
by gibco by therma fisher scientific
for everyone who is attending the
webinar today we know that understanding
cell culture is essential for the life
of your work
this gibco galaxy tour webinar aims to
connect you to gibco experts
who will share their knowledge and
experience in order to help you master
cell culture basics and achieve
consistent results
i would like to welcome our two speakers
for today
brittany balhaus cell biology r d
scientist from thermo fisher scientific
who will discuss a basic topic
introduction to cell culture
and then share her experience with the
thermo fisher cell culture products
she uses in the lab every day our second
speaker
chris scamlin is our senior global
market development manager
who is well versed in our fbs products
he will help you understand the basics
of fbs
and why you should be using gibco fbs in
your everyday work
let us welcome brittany to start the
presentation
thank you jennifer hello everyone as
jennifer said my name is brittany
balhaus
and i'm a research and development
scientist in cell biology
at thermo fisher scientific i've been
doing cell culture for about 10 years
now
and i'm very excited to introduce you to
the world of growing cells
and to provide some lessons learned from
my experience
today we will first discuss an overview
of cell culture
then go over some key terminology
next we'll walk through a typical cell
culture workflow and
examine the products that are required
for that process
finally i'll share where you can find
more information
on cell culture
so to start what is cell culture broadly
speaking cell culture is the process by
which you keep plant and animal cells
alive and dividing in vitro or outside
of the body from which they came
researchers researchers have been doing
this for more than a hundred years
now and we've gotten pretty good at it
we are now able to keep many different
types of cells happy
and healthy in vitro for extended
extended periods of time
keeping these cells happy and healthy
however requires very specific tools
that are dependent on the type of cells
you would like to culture
there are several critical components
that are common to all cell culture
workflows
the most critical component is of course
the cells
cells can be isolated from tissues or
procured from a commercial vendor
or even another lab however before you
get the cells in hand
you want to set up the environment
required to keep them alive
this involves several other components
first you need a complete cell culture
media
and supplements earth excuse me a
complete cell culture medium that is
made up of basal media
and supplements then you need a cell
culture vessel that is appropriate for
your cell type
and you need an incubator we'll go into
more detail on the media supplements and
culture vessels a little later on
now there are several main categories of
cell cultures
starting in the center here cell lines
are cells that can be cultured
continuously
this means that a researcher can put the
cells into a cell culture vessel with
medium
and the cells will divide until the
vessel is almost full
then a fraction of those cells can be
removed from that vessel
and placed into another vessel with
fresh culture medium
and that process can be repeated
indefinitely
primary cells on the other hand cannot
be moved from vessel to vessel
indefinitely
but rather they just stop dividing after
a while
moving to cell strain culture this is
when you isolate one particular cell
from the population
of cells in a cell line
that has some attribute you like and
allow it to divide
and make copies of itself over and over
again until you have a new cell line
that is different than the original
culture
now whether primary cells or cell lines
not all cells grow
in the same cell culture vessels some
cells need to anchor themselves down
to divide and this requires them to be
cultured
on a specially treated surface those
cells are called adherent cells
because adherent cells lay down and
spread on the cell culture surface
they are limited by the amount of
surface area in the vessel
you need to move a fraction of them to a
new cell culture
vessel periodically so that they will
keep dividing continuously
suspension cells on the other hand do
not need to adhere
to a surface in order to divide they are
perfectly happy
floating in the cell culture medium some
suspension cells
can be cultured in static conditions and
some must be agitated
for suspension cells
they are not limited by surface area but
rather
limited by the amount of nutrients in
the media
as well as the waste products that they
are secreting
so just like adherent cultures you must
periodically move a fraction of these
cells to a new culture vessel with fresh
culture medium
in order to keep them alive and dividing
you can see examples of the types of
culture vessels
or flasks you might use for adherent
versus suspension
culture in the pictures at the bottom
as discussed on the previous slide every
few days or so
you will need to move a fraction of your
cells from one culture vessel to another
so that the adherent cells
have more space and and the suspension
cells more nutrients
and they can keep dividing the technical
name
for this process is subculturing though
you will also commonly hear it called
passaging or splitting
it's important you keep an eye on your
ongoing cultures to make sure that they
are not
running out of space or nutrients in the
media and in order to judge the right
time
to passage your cells for adherent cells
you'll want to examine them with a
microscope often often
to see the proportion of growth surface
area that is
being covered by the cells
this proportion or percentage of the
area that is being covered
is called confluency it is detrimental
to your cell to be passage when the
confluency is too high
or even too low so typically you want to
passage the cells
when they're about 70 to 80 percent
confluent
are covering about 70 to 80 percent of
the available surface area
there is no confluency for suspension
cells rather
it is referred to as density which is
the
number of cells per volume of media
during the passaging process you'll
ideally count your cells to know what
volume of cell solution to seed
or put into your new culture vessel
when counting is best practice to also
check the cell viability
or the percentage of cells that are
alive in your culture
next if you're growing stem cells you
may be familiar with the round clusters
of cells pictured
in the middle here those clusters which
originate
from a single or small number of cells
are called colonies
and you often want to maintain small
fragments of those colonies when you
passage stem cells
finally on the right we have
contamination
if you notice that your cell culture
medium is cloudy or you see fuzzy stuff
growing in your flask you likely have
bacterial or fungal contamination
respectively
when you're doing cell culture it is
extremely important
that you follow the rules of aseptic
technique to reduce the risk of
contamination
so more on aseptic technique aseptive
technique is a set of guidelines that
helps prevent contamination from
microorganisms
it is done in a specific workspace known
as a biosafety cabinet
also known as the cell culture hood
aseptic technique
bio biosafety cabinets and personal
protective equipment
or ppe work together to keep you safe
from the cells
and also keep the cells safe from you as
an example of how these practices
coincide
upon entering the lab i put on my lab
coat
safety glasses and nitrile gloves
i go to the biosafety cabinet ensure
that the fan is blowing at full capacity
then spray the entire inside down with
70
ethanol i minimize the number of times
that i move my hands in and out of the
biosafety cabinet
and i always spray my gloves down before
with 70
ethanol before bringing my my hands into
the hood to work and both of those
things are part of good aseptic
technique
so as you can tell aseptic technique is
truly key to keeping your cell cultures
healthy
so please visit the gibco cell culture
basics website
to watch a video on how it works and to
learn more
now let's go through an example cell
culture workflow which is
subculturing or passaging adherent cells
as we look at the process in more detail
we'll discuss the specifics of the
products you'll need to successfully
culture your cells
the first step we'll talk about here is
dissociating adherent cells from the
growth
surface in most cases your cells will be
pretty firmly attached and spread on the
plastic
of the culture vessel so with this step
you add a reagent to the flask to get
the cells to let go of the plastic
all up and float in solution so that
they can be removed from the vessel
here is a typical dissociation protocol
for adherent cells
first you aspirate or remove the cell
culture medium from the vessel
then add a saline solution to wash the
cell
monolayer and remove any residual medium
then you remove the saline solution and
add in this dissociation reagent
and incubate the cells so that they lift
off of the plastic
after the incubation period you'll want
to check the cells on the microscope to
make sure that they are all free
floating
and if they are you would then quickly
add fresh culture
medium to the vessel to dilute the
dissociation reagent
finally you'll be able to move the cells
to a conical
and continue with the rest of the self
subculturing workflow
from this protocol i'd like to take a
minute to talk a little bit more about
saline solutions and dissociation
reagents
so there are many uses for buffered salt
solutions otherwise known as saline
solutions
in the cell culture lab and depending on
your purpose
you may want to choose different types
for
cell washing during the subculturing
workflow
you will want to choose a saline
solution that does not have
any calcium or magnesium since those
components can reduce the effectiveness
of the dissociation reagent
however if you need to keep the cells in
saline solution for
a longer period of time you may want to
use
a saline solution that has has calcium
and magnesium
in there so that the cells will be
happier over that period of time
theo red is a very useful compound that
gives you a visual indication
of how close to physiological ph
your solution is i typically don't see
this compound in my saline solutions
but i almost always have it in my cell
culture medium
with the compound in there uh yours
if your solution is at physiological ph
so around 7.4
then it'll be red if the solution is
acidic
it will be yellow and if the solution is
basic
it will be purple with
in that way it is you can easily tell
whether or not your solution
will be good for your cells
and and at that physiological ph
another common component is sodium
bicarbonate
which helps keep the ph neutral
so remember to check the scientific
literature or
in the product literature to decide
which version
of buffered salt solution is appropriate
for your both your cell type
and your application
most dissociation reagents are enzyme
solutions that break down the proteins
that keep the cells attached to the
growth surface
that's why when you add it your cells
will release from the plastic and ball
up and float in solution
from that point forward in the passaging
process you can
treat them like suspension cells it is
important that after your cells lift
you do add that complete cold cell
culture medium
in order to dilute the dissociation
dissociation reagent
so that it doesn't damage your cells
when looking for dissociation reagents
you will want to choose one that is
appropriate for your cell type
and your experiment one dissociation
reagent
that i really like when i culture cell
lines
is our triple product pictured here
whereas
trips and edta must be stored frozen
triple is stored at room temperature so
i never have to worry about aliquoting
and thawing it
as i get ready to passage it is also
gentler on cells and protects cell
surface proteins as you can see from the
data at right
so if this is appropriate for for your
cell type i highly recommend
using triple it's a great product
so back to our cell culture workflow now
our cells have lifted off the plastic
and are in solution and the next step
is to count the cells and so this is
where you would pick up if you were
growing suspension cells
as i mentioned earlier i highly
recommend checking viability
and counting your cells every time you
passage
so you can quickly determine if
something is going wrong in your culture
like if your culture is contaminated for
instance
so how do you check viability and count
well
the traditional way is by using a device
called a hemocytometer
pictured on the far left here to use it
you add
your cell solution to a grid that can be
seen on the microscope
and you manually count the cells
within the grid squares if using a
hemocytometer i recommend counting a
total of
three of the four outer grid squares and
using the average
from the average cell count you can back
calculate the concentration of the cells
in the solution
that same process is done automatically
for you
with the countess automated cell counter
for both however i also recommend that
you dilute your cell solution
one to one with tripan blue and you
would need to account for that
one-to-one dilution on the hemocytometer
but that's how you check cell viability
if the tripan blue gets inside the cell
that cell is dead and you'll want to
exclude it when you calculate how many
cells you should seed into your new
vessel that way you're only feeding
cells
that are alive using a hemocytometer
will
absolutely work for maintaining your
cell cultures but if you need really
high reproducibility
between counts or in counts between you
and another researcher you may want to
consider
the this countess automated cell counter
and as shown by the reduction in user to
user variability
in the data at the right
so now you know that your culture is 95
viable
and you have calculated how many cells
you want to add to your new culture
vessel
the next step is to fill your culture
vessel with fresh complete medium
so let's talk more about what complete
culture medium is
the majority of complete culture medium
is called basal medium
there are many different types of basal
media out there but they are all
basically a mixture of salts amino acids
vitamins and sugars like the buffered
salt solutions we spoke of earlier they
also include buffers
that maintain ph in a range that keeps
cells
happy and most also have phenol red so
that you can tell that the ph
is physiological the phenol red is
especially useful
for culture media since cells
will make the media acidic as they
divide and eat up all the nutrients in
the media
in other words the media in your cell
culture vessel will go from red
to yellow as the cells grow
when the media is yellow it is very
important that you immediately change it
to keep your cells happy
before using basal media for your cell
culture
you usually must supplement it with
additional nutrients to make it complete
we'll talk more about those supplements
in a moment
with more than 100 different kinds of
basal media out there
you'll likely want to read the
scientific literature
or ask your colleagues for advice on
which formulation of basal medium
is most appropriate for your cell type
one other thing to note on basal media
and
about actually many other cell culture
reagents as well
is that the components of the products
are light sensitive
which means that after a certain amount
of exposure to light the
media or the reagent will stop working
as well
therefore it's important that if you see
the little symbol that looks like
a little house with a sun over the top
of it on your product
you minimize the light exposure for that
product
this is especially important for our
bench stable basal media
as before it is supplemented with serum
it can be stored outside of the
refrigerator
at room temperature but
that media's sensitivity to light is why
it comes in a little cardboard box
so you need to store it in that
cardboard box so that it is it stays
protected from the light but again
all media and many other cell culture
products
are sensitive to light so it's good to
be aware of how much light they are
seeing
if your lab has refrigerators with glass
doors
you may want to consider covering the
glass for that reason
and if you store your media in a cold
room you need to be especially careful
and turn the lights out when you leave
keep an eye out for that symbol to keep
your media
and reagents working at their best
as i mentioned earlier basal media most
often needs to be supplemented with
additional components
before it offers your cells the complete
spectrum of nutrients they need
many cell types require serum like fetal
bovine serum or
svs and they also need a source of
glutamine
for glutamine thermo fissure has a cool
product called glutamax
typically glute glutamine must be stored
frozen but i like glutamax because it
can be stored at room temperature
so you don't have to worry about
aliquoting and thawing it
also glutamine in complete culture
medium degrades rather quickly
and glutamax is far more stable as you
can see at the data
at right this means that your cells are
seeing more stable levels of glutamine
over time
other supplements that are common for
more sensitive
cell types are are non-essential amino
acids and
a variety of recombinant proteins
you may also want to add antibiotics
like penicillin streptomycin or penstrep
to your complete culture medium in order
to reduce the risk
of contamination
so now let's take a little closer look
at serum and antibiotics
serum is the most used cell culture
supplement
as it has many many good growth factors
and nutrients in it
that make many cell types very happy
for all of the cancer cells that cell
lines that i grow i use 10
fetal bovine serum in my culture media
however because serum comes from animals
it is
considered undefined which means that it
varies batch to batch and can have
slightly different percentages
of specific growth factors or hormones
for instance
this undefined nature of serum was never
a problem for me
growing my cancer cell lines but for
some cell types or experiments
it may be for that reason thermo fisher
has specific versions or specialty sarah
that have been further validated to work
with specific cell types
like stem cells or that may be used for
specific purposes
like hormone studies we'll hear more on
sarah from my colleague chris
a little later on
as i referenced previously antibiotics
may also
be added to complete culture medium in
order to reduce the risk of
contamination
antibiotics are not a substitute for
good aseptic technique
however they are more like extra
insurance
they may also be extremely necessary if
you are working with cells that are
freshly isolated from tissue
or if you're trying to get a specific
clone to grow exclusively
for routine cell culture of cancer cell
lines for instance
you may not need antibiotics and may not
want to use them
as they can mask low grade contamination
and can be toxic to your cells long term
but if you're nervous about
contamination and especially if you're
new to aseptic technique
they can be a good tool to use
next let's dig in to the different kinds
of cell culture vessels a little bit
more
the most important things to consider
when choosing a cell culture vessel
are are you growing adherent cells or
suspension cells
and also to consider the purpose for
that vessel is it
scaling up or a downstream assay
most commonly you will probably use cell
culture flasks for routine culture for
industrial applications
where you need a lot of cells you may be
using bioreactors for your suspension
culture
for most downstream assays you will
probably want to use multi-well plates
where you can treat yourselves with many
different experimental conditions
finally if your primary goal is to
immunostain
and image yourself you may want to use
chamber slides so you can get the best
images on the microscope
if you're trying to decide how many
cells to feed into a new type of culture
vessel
are useful numbers for cell culture page
is also very helpful
and i use it often you can also explore
all
the many different options we have for
culture vessels at thermofisher.com
cell culture plastics
and back to our cell culture workflow
last but not least we have to check your
cells
regularly
it is very important to examine your
cells
at least once every two to three days in
order to make sure they're not
contaminated
that they're happy and healthy the kinds
of questions i ask myself when i check
my cultures
are the following what is the color of
my media
is it red is it yellow do i need to
change it
is the media cloudy or do i see an
unexpected
unexpected amount of debris that would
be an indication of contamination
is the morphology of my cells what i
expect it to be
what is the confluency of my adherent
culture
is it time to passage to judge
confluency especially you need to look
at yourselves under a microscope
often the one it pictured at right
is ours though any microscope will work
for routine culture one cool feature i
wanted to call out on this one
is a built-in confluency measurement
feature that it has
so everyone in your lab will be able to
judge compliancy
the same way but regardless of the type
of microscope you use
the most important thing is that you're
keeping an eye on your cultures on a
regular basis
it is also important to realize that
although we are pretty good at keeping
cells healthy
and dividing and the artificial
environment of cell culture media and
incubators
the cells are still growing in an
environment that is very very different
than the human body
this artificial environment can cause
individual cells that are better at
surviving and those non-physiological
conditions
to start to take over the culture since
they have
an adaptive advantage
over many passages this means that there
can be a
genetic drift of the culture and the
cells no longer reflect the original
stock of cells
to protect against this and to make your
experiments more reproducible
it is important to quickly expand any
new cells you get
and bank or freeze your cell stocks and
cryopreservation medium for later
use that way you can saw from your
frozen bank
alter the cells for 10 to 20 passages
then dispose of those and start again
from your bank's cells
this is best practice to ensure that
your cells don't drift
too far from the original culture
and that is all we have today i hope you
enjoyed this introduction to cell
culture
all the details from what we discussed
today can be found at thermofisher.com
cell culture basics including videos on
important topics like aseptic technique
thawing and baking cells
and passaging you can also find the cell
culture basics handbook which i highly
recommend
thank you for your attention
thank you brittany for providing such
wonderful insights on your
cell culture work i would now like to
invite chris scanlon to share more about
gibco fbs and how it is essential for
yourselves
thank you jennifer and thank you
brittany great presentation
um so yeah as jennifer mentioned i'm
going to go through my presentation
understanding the basics of fbs
and why choose keepco fbs and i
am as mentioned before i am a senior
global market development manager
at thermo fisher scientific and i've
been with the company
it's hard to believe but for 15 years
so let me dive right into the
presentation
so as i mentioned in the first slide i'm
going to really go right into the basics
of what
is serum i know a lot of people probably
on this um
on this webinar have heard of fps or
serum and have come across
it probably many times in their lab and
what serum is
is you know in very simple terms it's
that amber
color that you see in that bottle to the
right and it's basically animal stem
that has been
spun down through centrifugation
and it removes all the red blood cells
and you get that amber color that you
see in that bottle
and the most popular serum is the fps
and that's blood drug from a cow a
bovine fetus and actually
collected in a closed system which
basically means the system is not
exposed to air to keep
away any contaminants and why is it used
serum actually as brittany touched too
serum has been used
because it's a great reagent when it
comes to culturing cells
in a cell culture system really gives
you that viability and that really that
protection to ensure those cells thrive
in that environment
and it's used a lot for its growth
factors its attachment factors and many
other components as you can see here
there's over a
thousand components in serum
a lot of those things contain the
proteins electrolytes lipids
um and a lot of them are actually
undefined as well so i'll go more into
some of those details in a later slide
so what is it used for as i mentioned
and brittany i also touched on this as
well it's used in cell culture
to um just be a really it's the most
widely used reagent as well
when using eukaryotic cells and it's
also
within most cases it's used in all sorts
of applications
but the one serum as i touched on that
is really the most
favorite with researchers across the
globe is fbs somebody even call it the
magic bullet
and that's because it's it basically
works with so many cell lines
and primary cells as well so who uses it
both researchers and manufacturers use
um
this product in their cell culture
medium
and they use it for all sorts of things
that i touched on they use it for
vaccine production
they use it for animal diagnostics and
so much more
so important factors to consider in
serum selection as i touched on serum
protects cells
and protects for all sorts of things
like large ph
shifts toxic agents also another
important factor in serum selection is
cell growth not necessarily the
quickness of your cell growth some
people don't necessarily need
the cells to grow fast but it's really
around the focus on consistency and
reproducibility that is
paramount when it comes to using serum
in a culture system
and also no detectable contaminants
contaminants that can be introduced as
well obviously that's a very important
obvious thing that's um you know for you
to consider when selecting serum
and this is kind of an overview of all
the all the things that we know that
that's actually insane there are rich
sources of that in serum all sorts of
animal serum even more so in fetal
bovine serum
and as i mentioned before it provides
the most robust cell culture system
for the widest range of cell types for
both cell lines and primary cells and
that's why people
love not only sarah but most importantly
fps
and that's because they can just buy
that fps
and have it across all the cell lines or
primary cells they're using their lab
rather than buying various reagents that
might be you know
more conducive to certain applications
and then other ones for you know maybe
that are animal origin free
the fps really provides that ability to
work across all those cell lines and
really offer that one reagent solution
and as you can see it has lipids
hormones
various nutrients for growth um buffers
so it's a really great thing the only
thing that i know for a lot of
researchers that causes a little bit of
um
hesitancy with sarah is that it's
undefined even with all those great
elements that are in there there's still
elements
to this date that are undefined and
people have been using serum for
over almost over 60 years now and
it does vary from a lot a lot because of
that undefined element
but typically when people are using
ceremony tend to use anywhere from five
to ten
percent um in their basal medium it
tends to be the concentration they use
and they can vary again based on the
application
so what causes researchers you know when
they're choosing fbs what concerns them
the most
especially with fbs it's the price
fluctuation
and i'm gonna go into a slide coming up
and what why price fluctuates but that
is definitely a concern
um you know knowing that they have in
many cases a certain budget that they
can spend on all their reagents and
other things they need in the lab
they want to really make sure that they
can control that price when it comes to
fps also the product integrity they want
to make sure they're getting a product
they can
deliver on that consistency that i
mentioned before also supply continuity
depending on what fps you're using
sometimes the supply can be plentiful
other years it might be tight so knowing
kind of working very closely with their
suppliers to ensure
they have that supply continuity
especially those who are using a lot of
it
also lots a lot consistency as i
mentioned with the undefined element
it's very important that they have that
consistency
because that really helps them get to
that angle in many cases of getting
published
and also reproducible results that's
also tied into ensuring that they can
get published
and other other folks see that
publication and can reproduce those uh
same results that
was done in a particular lab that that
actually got published and finally
workflow solutions sometimes people
don't think of this but a lot of
researchers like to see if there's
workflow solutions that can
enhance or or speed up their workflows
one
one quick example is our one shot which
is pre-aliquoted
50ml bottles so those are things that a
lot of times customers
maybe might not initially think about
but when you offer that to them they
really like those options they can
really reduce
time as well as the risk of
contamination
so as i mentioned before price and flux
and supply can really fluctuate and this
slide really talks to the market
dynamics of the global sarah market
um one thing that's important to note
with sarah is that we have really
very little control over the supply we
are a byproduct of the meat packing
industry so we need more supply
in a calendar year it's very unlikely we
can get it
by going to the meatpacking um average
hours and saying we need more it's
really not up to us it's up to the meat
industry to really dictate the kind of
supply we can get so we really have to
think
you know farah had to really plan
accordingly and work with our customers
to understand their needs
to ensure we can um have their model
supply that will be necessary for all
our customers to do their research
and as you can see here there's a lot of
things that drive this a lot of things
sometimes people
don't even think about like whether it
be weather patterns i know folks
probably hear all the time that there's
droughts or floods that happen around
the world
and those that can have some you know
serious impact on the serum industry
for example when there's droughts in
australia what has to happen a lot of
times they bring those cows
to the abattoir or also in a
slaughterhouse because they just can't
they don't have
because of the drought they don't have
the food the water all those kind of
things
so they have to bring them to market
which basically brings more serum into
the market so for short term it's a
really great thing for researchers
there's more serum in the market
long term than there's a process of
rebuilding and there's all sorts of
other things that can happen
you know with the beef and dairy demands
also with market behavior with things
that can happen in the market that are
unpredictable
like we just saw with kova the pandemic
so all these things play a part in the
volatility sometimes
with fps and serum and as you can see
the cross index we have on the left
it really shows you since 2002 the
fluctuation of of the cost of
of the raw material over the calendar
over the you know
almost 20 years now and also the cost
volatility comparison a lot of people
are
very so familiar with corn crude oil and
gold as a commodity
but as you can see here aussie fps
australian fps and usfps
have more volatility than some of the
more common commodities that were
you know we use every day so like i said
we really have to plan and sometimes
things are unpredictable want to be a
pandemic or a certain weather
situation that can cause things to
change quickly so
that isn't why the market can fluctuate
when it comes to price and supply and
this is just a really simple way of
showing it
when there's drought you know high feed
prices to feed the cattle
you know high beef demand also you know
brings more to slaughter
which basically means more serum and
when it's heard rebuilding after these
kind of things happen when there's a lot
a lot of powers brought
to process this tends to be a couple
year process of rebuilding those herds
if they're allowed to if the weather and
so on
is conducive for rebuilding and because
of that that means there'll be less
serum to offer and price from that point
can go up and also
um supply can be tight
i'm not going to show you today but
there's a great video that really brings
us all together very brief but we
kind of explained why prices fluctuate
hopefully i explained it
as clearly as possible but if you want a
reminder or you want to share this with
a
colleague of yours please go to our
thermofisher.com forward slash
fbs to check out this video that really
summarizes it very nicely
okay so gibco the world of gibco and
where our um
fbs came from almost 60 years ago now
it'll be next year with gibraltar
celebrating
60 years in cell culture it's
unbelievable how long it's been around
but
gibco comes from grand island grand
island's a small little island
in the niagara river between the u.s and
canada it's part of
new york state and in 1962 is when
dipco came to be and like i said it's
it's been a huge impact on on the cell
culture market ever since
and it continues to be so it continues
to be that
as we move in um into 2022 and beyond
one thing i want to um stress the
one reason why a lot of scientists
recommend
gibco sarah is really for you know five
key areas innovation we're always
innovating a market that you know
most people look at as a commodity it's
been around for a while as they touched
on
but we're constantly innovating whether
it be the product in the bottle the
bottle itself
or technologies around that i'll get
into a little bit more detail
in the upcoming slides also the quality
we take a lot of pride in our product
we want to make sure we have the highest
quality and
we take all the measures to do so we're
also the most cited
um that means people are using our
product our fps and our other serum
and getting results and are able to get
published because of that so that
gives a lot of confidence for others who
want to achieve the same goals
to buy that product and hopefully at
some point in their research current to
get um
published as well but as most trusted by
pharma um
14 of the top 15 firework companies use
our product whether it be for vaccine
production
or other therapeutic purposes so it's a
widely used with
um a lot of the big pharma companies and
also our breath of life we have a lot of
products a lot of want to be our value
fps our premium
or specialty line of fps a lot of things
to offer for all the different cells
or applications our researchers are
using
so these are seven reasons why gibco fbs
and as i mentioned before it's not all
about what's in the battle and what it's
what also
transcends about here at gibco and
thermal fissure scientific we always are
trying to
find ways to better you know cell
culture research for the
for our end users and whether we can
make the product inside the bottle
better the bottle as i mentioned or
other things to really enhance that
that's what we look to and one thing
that we take a lot of pride in is that
we're
we're a vertically integrated supply
chain i'm going through that um what
that means in detail but that's
something that we take a lot of pride in
also the fact that we're isia
traceability certified isi stands for
the international serum industry
association
that you have to get certified to get
that traceability mark
also that we're um cgmp of compliant as
well as iso certified
again very high quality standards having
those certifications and also
the innovation in the bottle i touched
on one shop briefly but we also have our
boxy bottle that's been out since
2006 and was ergonomically designed to
make for easier use
in the lab and also our fingerprinting
um
this allows us to give more origin
reassurance especially when you're
you're paying for those premium flavors
like australia
new zealand and us and we also have
our um our image
cereal out matching tool this is a tool
that our customers love
right now we primarily offer the image
tool in
our north america and europe markets the
sewer will be bringing that
to to everyone that who buys our serum
and i'll tell you a little bit more
about that tool
in a few slides and then finally we have
our brother portfolio our products in
cell culture
work very well together all our
researchers in the lab use our products
together when i say
use all of them it's not only our fps or
serum it's also our cell culture media
reagents
and our nung plastics and we know they
work well together so when you buy them
together you should
the goal is to get great you know
optimal results so
that's another thing to consider that
you can come to us and get all your cell
culture requirements in one place
i've kind of touched on this a little
bit already but as you can see
um both our bottles we really take a lot
of pride in innovation
these are bottles design the gibko boxy
bottle is actually a misfocus it came
out in 2008
and this was designed really thinking
around how customers use
their media bottles and obviously we use
it for fps as well but it's really
has the wide mouth for easy pipetting
and pouring a lot of other nice elements
that really make it
a very user friendly model in a cell
culture lab
and in the one shot this is a bottle
that was designed specifically for fps
use and you know it can take the abuse
that
you know bottles like that take when
using an fps the
free spa cycle you know putting it in a
hot water bath
also not having to avoid it's a huge
benefit of these bottles as i mentioned
before but also it creates actually
less weight we know anywhere between 80
to 90 percent of researchers aliquot
their fps
into conical tubes and this bottle
removes all that element so northeast uh
serological pipettes you don't have to
use conical tubes
as well as the bottles that the fps come
in so it actually reduces
plastic waste by 33 which we know is a
big issue
in most labs around the world
and as i mentioned before vertically
integrated um supply chain sounds like
what the heck is that
what it is in the simplest terms is that
we actually probably about 70 of our
supply we have thermal fissure train
collectors
in the abattoirs or slaughterhouses
collecting the serum from the source so
we have that oversight
all the way through the whole process
all the way to the bottle getting into
your lab so it really ensures
a couple things traceability at the
highest level but also minimizes risks
of contamination
as well which we know a lot of our other
our competitors
most of them rely on third party so
having that oversight is a really we
take a lot of pride and we really want
to talk about
that because it really helps us drive
that quality message
also i'm not going to go into too much
detail on this slide but
what we like to talk about is our
extraordinary measures of all the things
that we do
from collection all the way through to
all the little add-ons that i touched on
already with our bottles
our eye match tool this video series
really shows you the details
where you can see what we do to make our
fps and when you have a chance
like i said before go to
thermofisher.com forward slash gibco
and have a chance they're very brief
videos on average they're about
80 seconds in duration and but they give
you a great insight to what we do to
make a great
quality product
as i mentioned before we have the isi
traceability certification we've had
that since
2014. we take a lot of pride in it we've
been involved in isi for
for a long time ever since his inception
back in 2006
and what the traceability program does
it maintains a record of traceability
from
the origin throughout the supply chain
so if anyone ever wants to see
those records we can offer that to them
just to show that traceability
and to ensure whatever it's saying on
the bottle is what's in the bottle
and another thing we take a lot of pride
is we have manufacturing sites around
the world
that gives us the capability to continue
to manufacture one of the highest level
but also have the capabilities
at various sites to continue that
manufacturing if any one site was ever
impacted by
weather or any other kind of event so as
you can see here we have our
initial site which is in grand island
new york we have one in scotland as well
as
two in auckland and new zealand in the
anz region
um sorry aqua new zealand newcastle
australia sorry so we have two in that
region as well
i already talked to the one shot but one
thing i want to read on this one i
really think
brings to life the benefit of the one
shot is that this came from a lab
at the university of washington in st
louis
and this was from a person that was an
early adopter of
our one shot fps and really loves the
bottle and continues to use it
to uh to the present day and what she
mentioned is that this bottle allows for
the convenience of speed while
maintaining a sterile product
as we have lots of undergrads in our in
and out of our lab
this ensures that one mishap with not so
aged hands
doesn't ruin a whole pack of fps so
outside of all the other benefits this
is another one that really stressed
why people really love the aliquot free
solution that is our one shot
so gibco fbs fingerprinting this is
something that we actually
work with a group called oritain to
develop some years ago
that again really helps give origin
reassurance and reason why we did that
there were some unscrupulous
suppliers in the past that would claim
you know what was in the bottle was
australian origin
when it was a concoction of different
origins um
it could have been australian u.s and
australian all mixed into that bottle
and the reason why that's important when
you're paying a premium for a product
like australian fps you want to make
sure that what's in the bottle is living
up to this and that's
what fbs fingerprinting provides and
actually uses trace elements from those
environments
to be able to confirm it is one of the
australian
new zealand or us we do it for our
premium fps
because this is those are the products
you pay a premium price
for so this is a great technology that
gives our customers that reassurance
for those products
and as i touched on before imagine is a
tool that our customers especially in
north america
and europe at the moment absolutely love
it's a tool that allows
our service specialist team to work with
our customers
to find them the perfect match whether
they use their previous giftco lot
number
or they use specifications that matter
most to them whether it be their
endotoxin
hemoglobin glucose the list can go out
we can take those numbers that mean most
to you put it into our eye match tool
and find that perfect match and what
that means for a lot of researchers one
they no longer have to test reduces the
money and the time it takes to test on
average
most research researchers take two to
three weeks at least to test their fps
it also shows that there's going to be
the performance they need they're going
to get that
from a match that meets a high standard
to their previous lot
it also helps you know increase the
confidence in the in their research
results so
this is a great tool and one reason i
wanted to really talk to it that
in 2022 we're bringing this tool to the
customers it's going to be a
customer-facing tool where
customers can go onto thermofisher.com
and use it themselves to find that match
to find what we have currently in
inventory that meets their closest
specifications and then they can
purchase that online and continue on
with their research with those
consistent and reproducible results
and another thing we did very recently i
think it's about three years ago now we
we
re-simplified our categories we had we
thought we had pretty clear categories
but we found out after
quite extensive research that a lot of
customers still weren't clear on how you
delineated between our five categories
that we had prior to the three
and we did a lot of work and we really
simplified our categories to make that
process of selecting the right one
for the for our researchers a lot easier
so we have now we have
a value a premium and a specialty and
it's easy to
do as i mentioned before for example our
value has up to 50 tests
our premium up to 96 and our specialty
their own
breed of products like our charcoal
stream exosome depleted
the list goes on so it really helps some
uh researchers come to the site and
really decide what makes the most sense
for them depending on the cells they're
using
or the application they're dealing with
and finally i'd like to you know touch
on a great tool
that you can go to at thermofisher.com
for slash fps
to download it's a gift card serial
guide buckle it gives a nice overview of
our categories
touches on a lot of things i touched on
during this presentation about
what makes kipko unique why people
choose giveco
a little bit about our our history as
well it also talks about um our image
zero out matching tool
so i highly recommend check out this
tool for more information
or at any time you have more questions
don't hesitate to reach out to your
thermo fisher
sales representative our um our
customer service or our tech support
we're always here to help or answer any
questions you have so
i'll stop there i want to thank everyone
for their time and thank you for i hope
this
presentation as well as brittany has
been very helpful insightful
and really enjoy presenting this
information so thank you very much
well thank you brittany and chris for
your insightful presentations
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located in the far left of
your screen
now let's get started the first question
is for brittany
what do i do if i think my cultures are
contaminated
yes so that's a great question um
and um you know just
a little background so again this would
be
like especially if you're your cell
culture media is cloudy or your growth
rates are
off um or you see something fuzzy
you definitely um what they definitely
may be contaminated and so the next step
if if it's just if it's mold
contamination
there are a lot gloss cause if it's
bacterial contamination your media is a
little bit cloudy
i still recommend just throwing away
that culture and going back to
those cultures that you have previously
banked that's the safest option
however if this is a very precious cell
culture
and you can it's absolutely
irreplaceable
you can do a treatment with an
antibiotic
solution um so typically that's like a
five to
ten percent antibiotic solution that you
would wash your cells with
um or incubate your cells with for
adherent culture
over you know a longer period of time
changing it out four to five times and
then
putting the regular cell culture media
with your regular amount of antibiotics
back
in after the treatment but again i don't
recommend that unless it's a critical
culture that you can absolutely not
replace
all right thank you brittany and we have
another question for you
this question says my cells are growing
very slowly
what could be the potential reason for
this
yep so number one could be contamination
as i mentioned but
um beyond that um it
it also could have been that your cells
maybe got a little
too confluent if they're adherent cells
or if they're suspension cells you let
them go
too far um and got they got too dense
um you can get um if there's
especially in the case of adherent cells
you can you can have contact inhibition
which can
make your cells just stop growing um if
they're primary cells
um going beyond cell lines they might
just be petering out
so they will flow as those primary cell
cultures
age and unfortunately at that point
there's nothing you can do they're a
finite culture
in terms of cell lines yeah certainly
making sure that you're passaging
regularly
you're feeding regularly those are the
most important keys there and um
yeah not not letting them get over
confluent and of course
being wary in case they they may be
contaminated those would be the most
common
reasons i think
thank you brittany we have a question
here for chris
when considering purchasing my next
batch of fbs
what information or tools does gibco
offer that can help me find a similar
fps
as the previous lot i used
well i've kind of three quick um options
for you
um to apply now and one will apply in
2022 but the first one if you have
a current bottle of fps that you're
using from us and you have a lot number
which should be on the bottle
you can check with your um thermofisher
sales representative to see if any more
of that lot is available in inventory if
it is
that's your best option to drive that
consistency
number two a lot of those lots do sell
out
quite quickly um so the second best
option would be if you don't have it
already request
your um whether it be from thermo or
another supplier your certificate of
analysis which gives you all the
specifications
that are in that a lot of fps like your
endo hemoglucose
estrogen and from there you can look in
that certificate of analysis find out
what species
that you deem most important for your
research and then get
a new scientific analysis of available
inventory and compare the two and then
when you see the closest match
i would recommend that would probably be
your best option and then thirdly which
will be coming i can send in 2022
is our image uh cerallot matching tool
which will be a
global tool where customers can go
online put in their either their
previous giftco lot number
or specifications that matter to them
and find the closest match
in our available inventory so that'll be
something to be very exciting i think
for most
once that is available so those are i
would say the best options
for that purpose
thank you chris we have one last
question here and it's for britney
can you share the guidelines on media
selection for different cell types
so there's a lot of different media
options out there
as i mentioned even just basal media
there's a
more than 100 kind different kinds and
there's a breadth of many supplements
you can choose from as well
it's really cell type dependent you know
the first place i start
when the culture can do cell type is the
scientific literature
looking at protocols found there
of course your colleagues at your
university for instance may um will also
be a great resource there
the other thing i might recommend
especially for for newer products that
are out there and for
specialty cell types would just be going
to the thermofisher.com website and
typing in your
cell type and see if we have any cell
type specific options there for you
we have a wide variety of stem cell
media for instance
some of them are new for instance so
they might not be in the literature
quite yet but that doesn't mean that
they um
wouldn't be a great tool for culturing
your cells so
just doing a quick search there um i
would recommend
as well we have lots of great products
there
well thank you brittany this wraps up
our gibco galaxy tour webinar today
we would like to thank brittany balhaus
and chris scanlon
for sharing their knowledge and cell
culture experience
and we would also like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions for
questions we are unable to answer today
we will follow up with an answer via
email we hope all of you have gained
knowledge today that will enhance your
lab skills in the future
we would also like to thank lab roots
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
lastly we invite you to join us in
september for the next
gibco galaxy tour webinar which focuses
on
3d cell culture until then thank you
and goodbye